hey youtubers is charlie since there's a
whole bunch of Suicide Squad stuff
that's been happening lately I thought
it was time for a bonus video you know I
think one thing is clear you know based
on all the stuff that's coming from the
set the people making this movie do not
care how much we know about it going
into it Batman was just seen recently on
set chasing the Joker around and when I
say Batman I mean a person in a Batman
costume not Ben Affleck he wasn't seen
on set it gives you the feeling that the
story might be going to like an assault
on Arkham place especially because of
some of the images we saw Will Smith is
dead shot with Harley Quinn on the set
really what I think is going on is
they're just blending a lot of elements
from some really popular Suicide Squad
stories Batman assault on Arkham being
one of them but you know I think that
they're leaving a lot of classic John
Austrian during their to david ayers
calling it the dirty dozen of the DC
Universe but I'm also thinking of it is
a little bit of a raid redemption movie
if you haven't seen that movie is this
really awesome indonesian film it's
basically Batman assault on Arkham with
way more action way less talking if
you've never seen Dirty Dozen it's like
this Charles Bronson world war two movie
where you know prior to d-day this group
of people has to come together this
group of convicts has to team up to take
down a bunch of high ranking Nazis in
this suicide mission that was from 1967
the version of Suicide Squad as we know
it now you know created by John Austrian
der started in 1987 so you could say
that he drew a lot of inspiration from
the Dirty Dozen because I haven't done a
whole lot of Suicide Squad videos just
to get you guys pumped up for the movie
to get you prepped here are my top five
stories that I think you should check
out first starting with number five
Batman assault on Arkham the animated
movie this might be a Batman story but
really it's a Suicide Squad story with
Batman in it they just put Batman's name
on the movie so that it would sell more
copies most of the focus of the film is
the Suicide Squad itself since it's an
animated movie for a younger audience
you know I think it has a lot of silly
humor in it that we won't see in the
Suicide Squad movie the tone of that
will be closer to what Zack Snyder's
going for in Batman V Superman and the
Justice League franchise that he's
spinning out there will be humor I mean
it'll still be a funny film but it'll be
a little more tongue-in-cheek on to
number for the raid redemption basically
like the best example of what an action
film should be with like all the fat all
the excess
boiled out the really good thing about
this film is that you probably never
heard of any of these actors before so
there's no weird meta stuff going on
that takes you out of the story a SWAT
team is trying to take down a drug lord
who's on the top floor of a building
that he's turned into his personal
fortress the challenges they face is
they fight their way to the top floor
like on each of the floors becomes
progressively more difficult the
fighting style itself is pretty badass
think of you know a cross between like
classic John Woo and the kind of parkour
stuff you saw in Captain America Winter
Soldier the story is told from the
perspective of a rookie character on his
first day on the job you don't even need
the subtitles to enjoy it it's just the
perfect example of how you pace an
action movie that's not trying to be
another type of movie it's not trying to
be some gripping drama it's a badass
action film plain and simple on to
number three Batman mad love basically
the origin story of Harley Quinn so mad
love is actually by Paul Dini and Bruce
Timm you know two people from batman the
animated series was you know my personal
favorite Batman TV show of all time I
don't know if is ever gonna be topped
they go deep on Harleen Quinzel you know
one time promising psychiatrist who just
you know fell madly in love with her
patient and went on to become the
Joker's greatest sidekick it is a good
job of having fun with that while at the
same time showing you just how tragic
her life has been in how she could she
can totally step out from the Joker's
shadow if given the opportunity it's
easy to understand how some people think
that she's just a back up to the Joker
but in her own right she's an amazing
character I feel like whenever Margot
Robbie was cast as Harley Quinn this is
probably the story they gave her to read
so that she could learn about Harley's
character on to number two basically all
of Gail Simone's run on secret six that
started with the villains United story
arc and went all the way up to the new
52 she really explored what's going on
in Deadshot's headspace Will Smith you
know probably gonna be the biggest star
in Suicide Squad next to Ben Affleck if
he truly is in the film and it's not
just like a Batman suit cameo with
someone else inside it I don't think the
entire film is just gonna focus on his
character but given that Tom Hardy
dropped out in the film was originally
centered on Rick Flagg they might have
changed some things up and finally my
number one prep story Suicide Squad from
the ashes by John Australia himself this
is a story written by The Suicide Squad
creator like the person who wrote the
best Suicide Squad stories that invokes
a lot of the classic Suicide Squad
cannon while telling a modern-day story
it's really about all these bad
characters these Suicide Squad
characters picking themselves up after
getting their asses handed to them
Amanda Waller had been kicked out of
checkmate Rick Flagg jr. just barely
survived this nuclear blast almost got
his face melted off so he uses this very
arrow type storytelling device but he
flashes back to Rick Flagg juniors past
so Austrian her uses Rick Flagg to do
the flashbacks in the present day he's
like the connective tissue that
character but like I said that was
supposed to be Tom Hardy in the film he
dropped out was replaced by joel
kinnaman who played Robocop if you guys
haven't seen that movie will Smith was
cast so him being the bigger actor I
think that they might shift the film and
do flashbacks using Will Smith's
character using the dead shot character
we saw him on set in like pimpalicious
clothing so either Deadshot just dresses
like a pimp all the time or he's going
to be the connective tissue the film
arguably that should be Harley Quinn's
relationship with the Joker really i
think the connective tissue in any
Suicide Squad story would be Harley
Quinn's relationship with the Joker just
this is way more interesting than any of
the other Suicide Squad characters I
think a lot of that will be in there
because it seems like most of the film
is going to be them chasing the Joker
down but you could look at the fact that
Margot Robbie you know playing Harley
Quinn in Will Smith just did a movie
together called focus where they did
have a lot of chemistry together so you
can see how they might use Deadshot in a
Harley Quinn Joker storyline with in
this movie they kind of did that during
Batman assault on Arkham which is why I
keep going back to that story part of me
feels like a bunch of executives watch
that animated film after was done and
saw the people loved it so much and they
thought hey why don't we make a
live-action version of this here's my
big question for you though you know
given all the things we've seen from the
set which character are you most excited
to see I mean there are a lot of
characters in the film as cool as Harley
Quinn is and is curious as I am about
Jared Leto's Joker I am most excited to
see Cara Delevingne enchantress
seriously this movie isn't shying away
from metahumans we have Killer Croc as
long as he doesn't look like one of the
Koopas you know from the super mario
brothers old movie I think we'll be fine
king shark is also going to be a lot of
fun too David Ayer keeps reiterating how
much he wants to do this live action
they will
a little bit of CG touch up but most of
this is actually going to be practical
effects that's actually why we've gotten
so many pictures of the Batman chasing
Joker around on the street because
they're not filming it on a green screen
studio so it's actually quite a bit to
be excited about in this film as cool as
the action as you know it as much as I
want them to do like a DC raid
redemption movie this film would be made
or broken on the strength of its
characters I feel like they have enough
diversity of really good actors that the
film won't live or die on the strength
of Jared Leto's Joker performance but
he's definitely a big part of the
equation every superhero film is only as
great as its villain and in a film where
the villains are the heroes Jared Leto's
Joker is the closest thing we actually
have to a villain I suppose who you
think the villain is depends on which
character you identify with the most
since it's Wednesday my next video is
going to be my top 10 episodes from
arrow season 3 so be sure to subscribe
to get that I should add that up by late
tonight but if there's any Suicide Squad
videos you guys want me to do next just
leave requests in the comments just in
case you guys haven't seen it yet you
can click here for my top 10 episodes of
the flash this season and you can click
here for my flash season 2 promo video
it's like a small promo and my
predictions thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you